- [Voiceover] What's up KCon?
(crowd cheering)
- Hello Los Angeles!
- [Voiceover] These are
the Try Guys from Buzzfeed.
- We're a KPop band, we can do this.
- My name is Aimee, and I'm a professional
dancer, and I work with
a lot of K-Pop artists.
- How do we dance like K Pop stars?
- To me it seems like
25% purposeful walking
and 75% things I will never be able to do.
- K Pop artists really
have to focus on entire
bodily performance, and in unison.
It makes a spectacular show
for the camera.
- What kind of dancing background
do you guys have?
- Well, we just learned
Irish step dancing.
(frustrated yelling)
- [Voiceover] Do you expect
me to dance in these?
- [Voiceover] Yes I do.
- [Voiceover] What?
- I don't know what to do with my hands.
- I'm neither Korean nor a dancer.
- Yeah, yeah, Eugene's screwed.
- [Eugene] I lap danced
the shit out of Ned's wife.
- Eugene's lying.
- [Aimee] You guys are going to be
performing on the main floor of
the convention stage.
- No, there's going to be like,
thousands of people there.
- You guys will all be dancers and
K-Pop artists by the end of today.
- [Eugene] We have two hours to prepare.
- And we're using half of
that for this interview.
- Then why are we talking?
We've got to get to dancing.
- They train so long and hard and
incorporating singing, dancing,
acting, and those skills
are required of K-Pop stars.
- This mainly hits a lot of different
variations that K-Pop really covers.
We'll start with the boy band, EXO.
- Extra hugs and kisses.
- Step back.
- Oh no, it's already hard.
- Arms are going to be forward.
- Like I'm hugging Keith.
- And you're going to body roll.
- Oh my favorite part.
- Oh, so sexy.
- [Zach] We need a name
for our K Pop band.
TG.
- [Keith] TGIF.
- [Eugene] Try Guys Is Fun!
- Grammatically, whatever.
- You right leg is going
to come out, close.
- Oh, like a horse.
- What happens next?
- New part, each person plays a different
role or position.
Eugene, you'r TGIF's leader.
(everyone groaning)
- Sort of wrong but okay.
- You've got to tone it down, man.
- We're learning together, though, leader.
- I was just trying to lead.
- Leader's lead.
- [Keith] No you weren't,
you were showboating.
- [Eugene] I don't think people realize
how difficult K-Pop choreography is.
Their music and dancing is so syncopated
and groups like EXO, they take
years of training to perfect this.
(celebrating)
- You guys will be learning a super
girly piece.
- Yes!
- Sistar.
Move up, move down, yes.
- [Zach] Already a better dance.
- I wasn't born to be a dancer but I'm
trying my best.
- The pretty boy of TGIF goes
to, Zach.
(everyone cheering)
- Everyone's surprised.
(laughing)
- Feet are going to go out.
- Yes.
- Close.
- Out.
- Yes.
- Cool, cool.
- Got to stay back bro,
that's my time to shine.
- Where am I supposed to be?!
- Not there!
- [Aimee] The diva for you guys...
- I wonder who it could be.
- [Aimee] Keith.
(group cheering)
- I get to be a pretty girl.
- Shake it, shake it to Keith.
- [Zach] What I noticed
about Sistar and a lot
of the other girl groups is that while
their music and choreography is
really cute, it's also really sexy.
And that balance is extremely
difficult to pull off.
- Yes, I missed that!
- Can we end the song with a collapse?
- [Aimee] Big Bang.
- I hate that show.
- [Aimee] Super exciting.
- Not the Big Bang Theory.
- That show sucks.
- Touch Eugene's shoulders there.
- Let's smell him.
- Still smells good.
- We're going to be sexy,
we're going to be cool,
we're going to have confidence,
even when we're fucking up, which we will.
- [Aimee] TGIF's bad boy goes to Ned.
- Yeah, bro! Get some!
- [Eugene] Being a K-Pop
star is impossible.
- I feel like it's a lot of pressure,
these guys are under.
- I believe in these guys.
I know they can do this.
- Do you think we're K Pop ready,
are we ready to kill the performance?
- Oh my gosh, you guys totally
exceeded my expectations.
- One, two, three, exceeded expectations!
- Well these next group of guys, they all
seriously do not need an
introduction, correct?
- We're all wearing Eugene's clothes,
because they said dress like K-Pop artists
so we asked Eugene to give us
his wardrobe.
- There was like a brief window of
two seconds where everyone
caught a glimpse of us and they
were like (screams).
And then my stomach started going nuts.
I really have to poop.
- We literally put this
together in one hour.
- [Keith] We waited so much I started
forgetting it.
- [Zach] But once you got into the dance,
I had so much adrenaline.
- [Aimee] Give it up for the new K-Pop
group, TGIF.
(upbeat K Pop music)
- Here's a fun surprise, we were
the closing performance for the
convention center at K Con.
No one told us that
until we walked on stage.
We messed a little bit up, but people
had fun with us.
- Just by walking out there,
the crowd just screamed bloody murder.
Just by being beautiful
Keith and the rest.
I think it's beautiful Keith and the rest.
- [Ned] I didn't know there was such a big
hip hop influence in groups like Big Bang.
This music is turnt and
the dancing is fire.
(crowd cheering)
- This experience has been really special
for me because when I was growing up,
Koreans and Asians were not popular.
I just want to thank all
the K-Pop fans out there.
You're doing so much for advancing what
people think about Asians in media.
This has been really touching.
(crowd cheers)
- Oh my god, K-Pop, ya'll!
That was incredible.
- International K-Pop fans have
this shared notion of kinship.
- What up KCon, we are the Try Guys!
- [Suk-Young] The
excitement that people can
feel when they are exposed to Korean
culture is unique.
- I went from not knowing anything about
Korean culture to feeling like I've
totally been immersed in it.
Everybody's having such a good time.
This is a blast.
- So I think K Pop is here
to stay for a long time.
- Thank you all the fans,
and find us on the net.
(crowd cheers)
(upbeat K Pop music)
- Let's smell him again.
- No, no, no, don't smell me!